m'a fait vraiment mal c'est comme si je
m'étais fait clouer à la table leur ou
hard as se souvient bien de ce qui
devait être un simple examen
gynécologique de routine l'intervention
a été si brusque qu'elle a eu mal
pendant une semaine je sais qu'un pape
test n'est pas agréable puis j'en ai
fait d'autres depuis puis oui en effet
c'est inconfortable c'est pas censé être
drôle parce qu'on gratte un peu la paroi
utérine
mais là c'était vraiment pire le plus
traumatisant est venue au moment des
questions posées par la médecin
particulièrement lorsqu'il lui a confié
avoir une dizaine de partenaires sexuels
pendant l'année vers le regarde et me
dis juste en tout cas tu es occupé et
j'ai trouvé ça vaut moi je me suis
sentie comme une poubelle à ce moment là
il n'y a pas d'autre mot à l'époque leur
guarda ne comprenais pas ce qui s'était
passé mais elle le nomme aujourd'hui
c'était de la violence gynécologique des
gestes des propos ou des pratiques aux
formes très diverses qui peuvent avoir
des conséquences significatives sur les
femmes c'est les paroles qui m'ont le
plus blessé le jugement que j'ai vécu
qui m'a aussi mis très très mal à l'aise
les personnes qui ont vécu pvo j'ai
saturé une vie lorraine fontaine travail
auprès de femmes depuis plus de 20 ans
aucun chiffre n'existe sur les violences
gynécologiques et obstétricales au
québec mais il sait que c'est plus
commun que l'on croit quelle est
l'ampleur au québec on ne le sait pas on
ne peut pas mesurer on peut juste vous
dire qu'on entend des centaines de
témoignages on entend les femmes avoir
eu des expériences malheureuses la
docteure marie josée bédard s'intéresse
à la question depuis près de cinq ans et
l'offre de la formation sur le sujet et
sur l'importance d'un consentement
éclairé c'est infaisable de l'éducation
dans mon milieu saint-jérôme - notre
position est très claire par rapport à
cet état de situation on doit faire et
met tout en oeuvre pour que ça cesse et
selon la docteure francoeur ça passe
aussi par de la sensibilisation auprès
des patientes il faut encourager les
femmes à avoir à nous à nous dire leur
secret il faut que les femmes n'étant
pas le dire trop important à l'époque
j'ai été sonné puis je les ai mis dans
ma zone tiroirs de ma tête de toutes les
expériences un peu traumatisante
convient puis qu'on veut oublier et
j'étais comme un un spa grâce et sa
rivale était juste pas délicate puis ben
là c'est comme le réveil s'est passé je
pense avec beaucoup d'autres femmes car
ici comme ailleurs dans le monde de plus
en plus de femmes dénonce les mauvais
traitements subis sur la table d'examen
en france ces jours-ci c'est la
secrétaire d'état est gynécologue crise
ou l'asacar aux poules ou qui se
retrouve sur la sellette et les visée
par trois plaintes lors ward a songé luz
y apporter plein contre la médecin qui
l'a traité pour protéger les prochaines
patiente dit elle ici qui me permettrait
au canada montréal